[Music]
today's question comes from tom in
louisiana he says i'm 32 years old
married with one child and another on
the way i have a mechanical engineering
degree and have worked as a project
manager for the past three years we are
debt free except for our 158 thousand
dollar mortgage and we have 35 000 saved
in retirement during the pandemic i lost
my job where i earned 97 000 a year i
applied for numerous positions with no
success so i lowered my expectations to
look for lower paying opportunities i
received and accepted a job offer as a
project manager at a non-profit this
position pays me 67 000 with no benefits
however to my surprise i really enjoy
this position and the environment am i
settling should i continue to look for
bigger and better jobs with actual
benefits such as insurance and 401k
yes i would continue to look i think
it's great that he loves it but i i
don't think this is the the end game
long term
there's a a false dichotomy that pops up
a lot um
and the false dichotomy is is that the
only way i can find a job in an
environment that i love is if i'm
underpaid
then that's just not true
you can make actually great money
at a company you love
and that you know the environment is
awesome you just have to look for it and
find it
those things are actually out there
um there are good companies and that are
not non-profits and they do a good job
we're one of them by the way with
benefits we don't hire uh you know we
don't have any mechanical engineers here
so i can't help you with that but
but the uh but but the point being that
and our people are paid market and above
you know our pay grade here we go
constantly doing compensation studies to
make sure we're paying what the market
is
saying someone that position that type
of thing is worth we want to be at least
at that if not better
um
and you know we work really really hard
so that is it possible i i think um
i think you had it went through a scary
time
and um it probably
took some of your confidence away
it feels to me like you know this is
safe
and you don't want to stick your hand
out there in the cold again
you got tired of being cold and i don't
blame you for that
but um i i i think you've created then a
false narrative that's not true yeah
that would be false in other words yeah
and project managers are in high demand
even louisiana i think you can do better
than 67 000 with benefits and so there's
nothing wrong with working at this
non-profit and enjoying that but i still
would be looking for the other
opportunities i think you're probably
worth 110 in the market
and you just got to find some place
that's not a toxic environment and
you're not taking it just for the money
you're taking it because it's work you
like with a place you like
oh and by the way they pay really well
oh and by the way they have good
benefits but no i don't i don't ever
want someone to take a job just for
money and put up with horrible situation
or i hate my life or whatever it's not a
ken coleman thing it's not a ramsay
thing
so uh no i wouldn't do that but
the false dichotomy is is that the only
thing you only only get one the only
place you can work that's good is if
you're underpaid and that's just not a
that's not a true thing uh not a true
thing at all
generally speaking you're going to
really get paid
uh really well it's something you
actually love in an environment you love
that's not
you don't have to settle to have meaning
settle on the income side to have
meaning that's just not a true thing
good question very interesting
interesting